[Music]
ABC is getting us all excited for the
bachelor premiere Monday the network
aired this countdown to Knicks special
Sunday night taking a trip down memory
lane and teasing what's to come in the
new season
so I plead the fifth the first a big
reveal
contestant Liz owned up to meeting Nick
at bachelor in paradise couple Jade and
Tanner's wedding in January of last year
and from the sound of it the two had a
one-night stand at the end of the night
he asked for my phone number and I told
him no I haven't talked to him since I
have met Nick before we had sex how
would you react if any of your your past
women came back for cameos or anything
else um that would be interesting as far
as my relationships whether it's been on
TV or not my past is my past and while
I've hadn't been very fortunate need
some great women for me I feel like
those ships have sailed and could this
be our season villain 24 year old
Corrine is making bold moves and big
promises to the dismay of the other
women I saw is current taking her top
I hope Nick is not looking for a girl
like that
I just want Nick now and they will do
whatever it takes to make sure that at
the end is just meeting him I am NOT a
runner-up and my sex abilities are
definitely top notch so tonight I'm
gonna go see Nick and I'm going to have
sex with them
will you go the distance and get
physical with women before the fantasy
suites as the bachelor um probably not
I'm gonna use that time to you know
really get another women you know I'm
not gonna say you know it's still make
it steamy listen to this moment between
Nick and Rachel in your rare and
refreshing villain from Finland this
doesn't guarantee Rachel makes the final
three after all the bachelor is very
good at messing with our minds they're
cheersing to Finland in a press release
the network had revealed that the final
three women would go to Finland however
we could just be witnessing a moment
where they're excited to go
[Music]
you